bien que maintenant on va revenir
justement sur les découvertes
scientifiques d'importance
pascal eu beaucoup quand même en 2018 on
a vraiment repousser les limites autant
pour le corps humain que dans l'espace
au vent par alexis découverte avec le
journaliste scientifique renault
manuguerra gagner bonjour nos plus beaux
jours d'abord on a trouvé enfin une
réponse à une question qu'on se posait
depuis longtemps il ya vraiment de l'eau
sur mars
oui ça c'est des chercheurs italiens qui
ont fait cette découverte la 1.5 km sous
le pôle sud de la planète mars
donc on parle d'un plan d'eau qui mesure
une vingtaine de kilomètres de diamètre
sur au moins un mètre de profondeur mais
probablement a beaucoup plus et ses
découvertes qui a été fait grâce à la
sonde de l' agence spatiale européenne
mars express qui est en orbite autour de
cette planète là depuis 2003 et ça a
pris aux chercheurs trois ans
d'observations et de zande analyses
avant qu'on réussisse à déterminer qu'on
à faire qu'on avait à faire à ce lac
souterrain au parle justement de quelle
genre de la khl d'abord on parle d'une
eau qui est extrêmement froide voudront
vraiment loin au dessus du point de
congélation parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
de chaleur sur mars pour permettre une
eau plus chaude que ça c'est quand même
pas une patinoire s'est passé c'est le
service de l'eau liquide mais justement
pour que ça reste liquide il faut que ce
soit une eau qui est extrêmement salée
beaucoup plus salée que l'eau de mer on
parle d'un équivalent de la saumure
qu'on utilise pour conserver certains
aliments donc même si on dit que de
l'eau liquide c'est toujours un indice
de vie dans ce que si les conditions
risquent de poya être très propice mais
c'est pas impossible parce qu'on a déjà
vu des bactéries ou des êtres vivants
vivent dans des conditions extrêmes à
des kilomètres de profondeur sous terre
nous savons c'est sûr qu'ils vont être
extrêmement étudier au cours des
prochaines années
mais est ce que cette découverte cela
veut surtout dire c'est que maintenant
la chasse est ouverte parce que si on ne
trouvait un lac sur mars mais ça veut
dire qu'il y en a probablement d'autres
et cela veut peut-être qu'ils vont avoir
des conditions un peu plus propre et
c'est la vie on va rester dans l'espace
encore quelques instants pour une autre
découverte importante qui vient elle de
beaucoup plus loin
oui sauf pour la première fois on a
réussi à retrouver l'origine de ce qu'on
appelle des particules fantôme
donc ça c'est des neutrinos des
neutrinos sont des minuscules particules
qui forment les attendent et on les
retrouve aussi dans ce qu'on appelle
rayonnements cosmiques sont des
radiations qui existe partout dans
l'univers mais dont on connaissait pas
l'origine des variantes les plus
énergétiques donc à l'aide d'un
laboratoire qu'on surnomme le cube de
glace les chercheurs ont été capables de
retrouver l'origine d'un sinistre
hinault qui sont remontées à un trou
noir monstrueux ni les millions de fois
plus massive que notre soleil qui
activement en train de dévorer des
étoiles à 3.7 milliards d'années-lumière
de nous et c'est ces étoiles là qui met
les neutrinos dans les derniers moments
de leur existence avant d'être
déchiquetés par le trou noir
mais elles vont les maîtres havre
émettre ces particules qui vont
traverser l'univers en ligne droite à
des vitesses proches de celle de la
lumière et en septembre 2017 mais la
terre se trouver dans la trajectoire de
ces neutrinos qui ont été détectés par
le laboratoire cubes de glace cubes de
glace et la vie drôles de nos pourquoi
cette appellation
mais à ce parce qu'il détecte et
dell'utri nos c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement difficile normalement
elle ça traverse la matière sans
interagir avec quoi que ce soit mais
occasionnellement quand elles frappent
une particule directement comme par
exemple une molécule d'eau elles vont
émettre un bref flash de lumière qui
pourrait à être détectées par certains
appareils pour justement détecter ces
flashs des chercheurs sont allés en
antarctique
ils ont à un endroit où la glace était
particulier transparents ils ont creusé
des trous de 2500 mètres de profondeur
dans une région d'environ un kilomètre
cube c'est pour ça qu'on s'appelle le
cube de glace et ils ont mis cinq mille
capteur de lumière qui vont incapable de
justement détecter ces neutrinos donc un
neutrino frappé une des molécules de
glace ça va mettre ce flash et les
détecteurs ou incapables de de dévaluer
sa trajectoire et ça va envoyer une
alerte à plusieurs télescopes partout à
travers le monde qui vont alors se
braquer dans la direction devenu
lutherie nos essayer de détecter c'était
quel objet le emmy et donc c'est un
outil de plus qui nous rend capables de
mieux comprendre les phénomènes de
l'univers c'est ce qui s'est passé cette
année avec cet appareil
maintenant je voudrais qu'on parle quand
même d'une nouvelle qui est plus ou
moins passé inaperçu vraiment les gens
scientifiques se sont intéressés à ça
mais on n'a peut-être pas beaucoup parlé
c'est des bébés génétiquement modifiés
en chinois et ça c'est un phénomène qui
est arrivé c'est une histoire qui est
arrivée en novembre dernier c'est un
chercheur chinois qui annonçait avoir
changé l'adn de deux jumelles pour les
rendre résistantes au vih donc celle là
c'est pas une découverte en tant que tel
parce qu'on avait déjà
modifier génétiquement les embryons en
laboratoire avant mais c'était
uniquement rester en laboratoire et le
fait qu'il ait permis à ces embryons là
de se développer et de mener à des
naissances oui c'est une ligne qui a été
franchie cette année et c'est une
annonce qui devait arriver un jour mais
les chercheurs auraient voulu que ça se
fasse ça se fasse de manière beaucoup
plus encadrée et pour des raisons
médicaments beaucoup plus valides que ce
qu'on a vu
parce qu'il existe des manières beaucoup
plus simple et sécuritaire de protéger
des enfants du vih parce que lui la
technique qu'il a utilisée s'appelle
christophe castaing c'est un ciseau
moléculaire qui est capable de
reconnaître spécifiquement brindas dn le
retirer et de le remplacer par un autre
et c'est un outil qui a le potentiel de
vraiment aider à guérir des maladies
incurables mais si on utilise mal ça
peut faire plein de modification
génétique accidentelle ailleurs dans le
génome et ça ça aurait pu causer des
maladies beaucoup plus grave à ses deux
enfants locke key serait normalement
plus on n'avait pas joué avec leur adn
donc il va falloir suivre ses filles
être dans les prochaines années pour
s'assurer qu'elle soit en qu'elle soit
qu'elles soient en bonne santé et qu'on
soit d'accord ou non avec le geste est
un événement qui risque d'avoir beaucoup
de conséquences dans les années à venir
en tout cas ça fait beaucoup jaser dans
la communauté c'est oui ça c'est un truc
que beaucoup fait parler effectivement
renault manuguerra gagner toujours
fascinant merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir avant